[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition du grand jt des territoires sur
vos chaînes locales et régionales et sur
tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité près de
50% de français déjà vaccinées mais pour
aider les français les plus fragiles à
se protéger contre la coved des
associations aident les autorités
un reportage dès le début de ce journal
avec vos jetons et les visions dans les
yvelines les militaires s'entraînent
avant le défilé du 14 juillet sur place
les pilotes travaillent notamment pour
que tout soit parfaitement réglé le jour
j une préparation suivie par les caméras
de tv 78 dans un instant alain delon est
de retour ils s'expriment face au monde
l'acteur m'a accordé un entretien
exclusif sur tv5 monde
sa vie son parcours son regard sur
l'actualité et la politique vous en
découvrez en avant première un extrait
dans ce journal
et puis vous allez découvrir le courage
de niall une jeune femme de 21 ans
atteinte d'une maladie génétique rare ni
elle ne peut pas s'exposer au soleil et
doit donc sortir totalement couverte de
chez elle son portrait son courage c'est
avec tl7 la télévision de la loi à la
fin de ce grand jt des territoires
près de 33 millions de français ont reçu
leurs premières doses de vaccin contre
la copie de 19
la barre des 50% et donc proche parmi
les publics encore éloigné de la
vaccination les plus précaires dans les
vosges l' agence régionale de santé et
le secours catholique ont mis en place
un centre de vaccination éphémère son
objectif
vous allez le voir c'est vacciner les
bénéficiaires de l'association anne
didier et anthony sap pour vosges
télévision sur place la fracture
numérique parfois un sentiment
d'exclusion des réseaux officiels ou
encore une certaine méfiance vis-à-vis
des autorités autant de raisons pour les
personnes dites précaire de passer à
côté de la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc vide l'agencé régionale de
santé s'est donc rapproché du secours
catholique et de son espace solidaire
installés au centre-ville à epinal pour
y mettre en place un centre de
vaccination éphémère les bénévoles
vosgien du secours catholique ont tous
ou presque déjà reçu au moins une
première dose
place donc aux bénéficiaires de
l'association ceux qui le souhaitaient
en tout cas une transe
ten de rendez-vous était calé pour la
journée avec les vaccins johnson freezer
et modern certains non non non déjà pas
d'ordinateur certains n'ont pas de moyen
de locomotion donc aller jusqu'au parc
des expos même avec les cartes ça peut
être compliqué on l'aura bien expliqué
que voilà ça serait en confiance il
serait au milieu de gens qui connaissent
sont dans des locaux qui connaissent ils
savent qu on leur posera pas forcément
de questions autre que celle là qui
concerne leur santé
la confiance un facteur en effet
déterminant pour la plupart des
bénéficiaires en tout cas christiane et
armand se rejoignent sur ce point
au départ je n'étais pas trop d'accord
moi parce que j'avais pas trop confiance
dont elle m'a décidée qu'en mai puis
j'ai dit ben j'ai dit allez j'y vais
quand même parce que il faut vie il faut
y passer quand même un dur pour mes
enfants mes petits-enfants mes arrières
petits enfants depuis sur ribéry final
je suis accompagné par le secours
catholique déjà
avec l'alimentation que je prends mes et
qu'on m'a proposé ça ce sont des parents
m'ont dit ça je leur ai fait confiance
parce que je mange donc je crois que si
nous faut pour la vaccination pas si
l'on sait juger bien pour nous et cette
campagne de vaccination comme les mois
de crises traversées ont révélé les
fragilités du système hospitalier
français dans la sarthe habitants et
soignants se mobilisent pour sauver les
urgences de l'hôpital de saint calais si
elle ferme
il leur faudra désormais 45 minutes pour
se faire soigner
trop loin disent les concernés
explications d'hélène galiana pour vyas
lmtv sartre sur place pour certains
habitants
il y avait comme une sensation de déjà
vu en manifestant devant les urgences de
saint calais en 2018 déjà il s'était
mobilisée pour sauver ce service de
l'hôpital
ce mardi matin une centaine de personnes
s'est rassemblée pour dénoncer leur
possible fermeture
cevital moi j'y viens fichu encore venu
deux fois deux fois cette année
je bricole je me coupe et on n'a pas de
rendez vous chez le médecin dont
convient aux urgences c'est automatique
j'ai fait toute ma carrière en pharmacie
je n'ai pas eu les urgences combien de
fois on va les gens aux urgences les
gens se rendent pas compte de leur
gravité et si les plus durs j'en sais
ils verront pas soigneusement et
préférant rester chez eux quitte à
mourir
actuellement les urgences de saint
calais dispose d'un seul médecin
urgentiste titulaire alors qu'il en
faudrait plus de quatre pour que le
service tourne normalement c'est une
sécurité pour la population nous sommes
à plus de 30 minutes de tout centre
disposant d'urgence si ça ferme
il y aura une zone blanche entre saint
calais et château du loir et qui sera
dépourvu de secours pouvant se rendre en
moins de 30 minutes au moment où à
vendôme
l'association de défense de l'hôpital
n'exclut pas d'organiser une
mobilisation à paris avec les autres
services d'urgence du département menacé
pour dénoncer la situation médicale de
la sarthe dans le reste de l'actualité
les préparatifs pour le défilé du 14
juillet ont débuté dans les yvelines des
pilotes étaient réunis une journée sur
la base aérienne de vélizy-villacoublay
autour du général laurent l'herbe est le
commandant de ce défilé aérien
ils s'entraînent en vue du jour j gagner
l'avenir c'est le thème de cette édition
2021 nicolas d'andry de la rédaction de
tv 78 lui a gagné le droit d'assister à
une partie de la préparation
regardez il a lieu chaque année mais se
prépare bien en amont de manière
minutieuse et rigoureuse
le défilé aérien du 14 juillet rassemble
91 appareils hélicoptères avions
chasseurs différents aéronefs de l'armée
de l'air de la marine nationale de la
gendarmerie ou encore de la sécurité
civile avec une organisation
particulière le défilé qui est constitué
d'un ensemble de patrouille qui vont
attendre dans l'ouest parisien
qu'on leur donne le top départ est bien
se rejoignent petit à petit sur un axe
qui est la kz2 défilé et c'est bien par
le respect des altitudes le respect des
vitesses le respect des trajectoires le
respect des horaires
le respect des procédures radio que la
sécurité aérienne est garanti pour cette
journée à la base aérienne 107 de
vélizy-villacoublay tous les pilotes
chef de bloc sont réunis c'est le cas du
sous-lieutenant aurélien navigateur au
sein d'un awacs
un avion de l'armée de l'air doté d'un
radar charge à chacun dans son avion et
dans son son équipe de d'avion leader +
équipiers de préparer la mission au
mieux en traçant des cartes en préparant
visualisant sa mission avant et ensuite
pour être au rendez vous
répétition générale et le 14 juillet à
l'heure on est là vraiment pour assister
les pilotes et que puisse se concentrer
exclusivement à la main à la
manoeuvrabilité de l'avion
après le briefing du matin les pilotes
ont pu faire des repérages aborde
différents hélicoptères des points
d'identification de la défense à la
place de la concorde pour faciliter le
défilé pilote d'un mirage 2000d le
commandant nicolas sera suivi de cinq
mirage 2000d et de six rafale les
premiers repères qu'on essaie
d'identifier sont des repères avec des
développements verticaux qui nous
permettront en cas de mauvaise météo de
pouvoir nous affranchir de une
visibilité médiocre ou faibles donc
jusqu'à 5km de visibilité horizontale
pour pouvoir nous aligner sur la défense
et ensuite être axé parfaitement une
répétition générale du défilé aérien
doit avoir lieu fin juin dans le loiret
nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière dans le grand jt des
territoires alain delon est de retour
dans les médias
l'acteur victime d'un avc il y a deux
ans m'a accordé un long entretien pour
tv5 monde
depuis chez lui à douchy dans le loiret
un entretien qui sera diffusé d'ailleurs
le 1er juillet à 21h sur l'ensemble des
antennes de tv5 monde et durant lequel
l'acteur véritable star mondiale
reviendra sur ses souvenirs de carrière
s'exprimera sur l'actualité sur sa vie
privée aussi et son désir de revenir au
cinéma
regardez à ce propos cet extrait
exclusif pour vous vous disiez que vous
avez encore des envies
on apprenait en vie d'alain delon
quand on pourra pas dire que le courant
des virus n'est plus là ça fera quoi
aller faire une bonne mousse quelque
part voile un film là on reconnaît alain
delon quand film et surtout préférant
fumer faire son dernier film
ça sera le dernier c'est pas impossible
qui restera pour toujours
donc il devra être qu'exceptionnelles
devraient êtres humains et alain delon
dedans devra être lui aussi exceptionnel
jean foot 38 pour ça
un peu comme aujourd'hui sans transition
maintenant dans la somme
les équipes techniques du département
sont en pleine opération de faucardage
sur le fleuve
l'objectif c'est lutter contre le
myriophylle hétéro fils qui est une
plante aquatique exotiques qui
prolifèrent dans les canaux de la somme
et qui devient un véritable fléau pour
l'activité fluviale et pour la pêche
aussi regardez ce reportage de jérémy
houbron pour wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord sur place il est devenu l'ennemi
public numéro 1 dans les canaux de la
somme
c'est le myriophylle et pour lutter
contre la prolifération de cette plante
aquatique
rien de tel qu'un bon coup de faux quart
d'heure c'est comme une cisaille voilà
comme une barre de coupe de
moissonneuses batteuses en fait qui
vient
coupé qui vient ensuite j'ai mes
collègues qui sont à laval 2 où je suis
en train de couper quoi et
ils ont un bateaux ramasseurs donc ceux
qui se servent pour mettre en berge qui
est ensuite évacué en camion le
myriophylle hétéro fils en vaille la
somme depuis 2014 et peut pousser de 30
cm par semaine si bien qu'il devient un
fléau pour les activités nautiques
automatiquement la navigation devient
possible toutes les activités nautiques
deviennent impossibles
l'aviron
le canoë la pêche devient également
impossible
imaginez-vous pêcher dans un bassin
rempli de remplie d'herbe en fait un
remplies d'algues s'est pas
particulièrement difficile en sept ans
un million cinq cent mille euros ont été
investis dans cette opération une somme
nécessaire pour préserver les activités
nautiques mais également les écosystèmes
du fleuve selon la fédération pour la
pêche
on peut voir la densité de cette plante
est vraiment très importante et donc de
ceux sur développement ça va prendre la
place de deux espèces qu'on va avoir
nous localement et donc on va voir on
risque d'avoir la disparition de des
plantes aquatiques inféodés à nos
milieux initiaux 63 hectares seront
cette année traité d'ici la fin de l'été
les férus de poissons pourront retrouver
les joies de la pêche dégustation
restauration la question fait débat sur
le bassin d'arcachon où l'activité des
cabanes à huîtres est soumis depuis
quelques mois à une nouvelle
réglementation
désormais la dégustation des huîtres
doit représenter plus de 50% du chiffre
d'affaires des cabanes à cela s'ajoutent
de nouvelles règles quant à l'élevage
des huîtres trop de contraintes
décidément après des mois de fermeture
pour certains ostréiculteurs
ils ont donc décidé d'attaquer cette
nouvelle réglementation devant le
tribunal administratif de bordeaux
écoutez à ce propos olivier laban le
président du syndicat des ostréiculteurs
dégustateurs au micro de nos confrères
de tele7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
quand vous rentrez dans une dégustation
si ce sont des huîtres à destination de
la vente directe sont soumises à aucune
règle
si ce sont des huîtres à destination de
la dégustation sur place
il faut obligatoirement qu'elle se
retremper six semaines enfin il pour
nous les producteurs que nous sommes on
essaie d'être le plus pour cible
pragmatique et concret et cohérent
trouve ça un peu vraiment tiré par les
choses
le tribunal administratif de bordeaux se
prononcera donc dans le courant du mois
de juillet en faveur ou non des
ostréiculteurs du bassin d'arcachon des
huîtres toujours que l'on aime déguster
évidemment avec un verre de vin blanc et
du vin il en est largement question dans
le nouveau magazine lancé ce mois-ci par
le groupe reward médias qui s'appelle
tonnes un trimestriel qui veut combiner
bien vivre convivialité et savoir sur le
vin justement pour en parler nous sommes
en duplex avec sa rédactrice en chef
gabriel vise à vonnas bonjour bonjour
cyril ainsi beaucoup de me recevoir
gabriel vise à vonnas pouvez vous nous
présenter le positionnement éditorial de
ce nouveau magazine en quoi se distingue
t-il des magazines déjà existants dans
l'univers des vins et des spiritueux qui
sont nombreux on a décidé de partir à
360° de ce qui peut exister aujourd'hui
dans l'univers des vins et spiritueux
il ya une poignée de revues
effectivement en france mais elles sont
surtout dédié à un public de
professionnels c'est plutôt des revues
'b to b' donc avec tout ce que ça
implique derrière un vocabulaire
compliqué des dégustations de vins qui
sont exhaustifs sur les régions avec
talent un que je vous montre ici c'est
très joyeux coloré déjà dans sa forme
c'est très différent et ensuite dans le
fond on a voulu se recentrer sur le
plaisir sur le divertissement
on vous raconte est loin aussi à travers
des histoires de femmes et d'hommes qui
le font bien évidemment lorsque nos
conseils de sélection demain on a une
belle équipe de dégustateurs et le but
c'est pas de faire de vous imposer notre
goût mais justement nous faire
comprendre par les mots simples et
justes et une approche métaphorique 10
ans chez moi ils tous deux finalement et
vous donner envie de les goûter de les
déguster avec nous alors que trouve-t-on
tout au long de ces 130 pages de ce
premier numéro
tallinn trimestriels donc là il va
accompagner les mois de juin juillet
août et donc on a voulu faire un dossier
spécial sur ce vin qui est souvent un
petit peu des criques et que le rosé on
entend souvent dire oui le rosé c'est
pas vraiment du vin on peut mettre des
glaçons de dents etc
on parle aussi entre autres dans le
rhône notamment à la rencontre du
vigneron célébrissime jean louis cha
on s'interroge dans ce numéro sur le
negroni quelle est l'histoire d'une et
l'euro ni quelles sont les recettes
inégaux ni comment bien faire là negroni
sur la bière aussi une rubrique sur la
bière on s'intéresse à la bière pression
aux spiritueux aussi un petit peu et
puis on est aussi parti déjeuner avec
laurent gerra laurent gerra qui bon
spectacle qui va bientôt sortir
s'appelle sans modération donc c'était
ça tombait à point nommé qui est un
grand connaisseur de vin et qui est
aussi associé dans plusieurs domaines
tan a fait un magazine qui fait du bien
à l'heure de l'été et après tant de mois
passé confiné et comptera dans nos
libertés c'était ça le but
oui je pense que effectivement tout le
monde a envie de retrouver ses amis de
sortir un nouveau le vin a un pouvoir
fédérateur illégale et dont bien
évidemment se retrouver ensemble autour
d'un bon vin ça fait pied ça fait partie
des quinze ire de là les prochains
numéros en septembre pouvez vous nous
dire déjà ce que l'on pourra trouver
dans ce numéro 2 tanon numéro deux va
être en kiosque 8 septembre
on reste concentré sur les deux plus
grandes régions françaises
on va aussi s'intéresser à la vodka
notamment on va parler de tout un tas de
deux vignerons des jeunes des plus âgés
et bien sûr nos sélections nos coups de
coeur est nommé aux affaires
merci gabriel vise à vonnas d'avoir été
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires
pour ceux qui sont intéressés pour
acheter le magazine tana et bien ce
nouveau magazine du groupe ray wang
médias est disponible dans les points de
ventes des boutiques nicolas et repaire
de bacchus au prix de six euros 90
l'économie dans nos régions maintenant
avec vous michel picot vous allez nous
présenter une pme qui s'appelle précise
dès qu elle se situe dans la sarthe une
entreprise qui fabrique d'ordinaire des
pièces pour l'aéronautique et le spatial
et qui a su se réinventer pendant la
crise elle crée désormais une pièce
métallique utile pour nous tous son nom
l'attachante bonjour cyril bonjour à
tous je vous emmène aujourd'hui à la
ferté bernard dans la sarthe pour
découvrir la pme précise dès qu une
société de mécanique de précision
il use in des pièces métalliques très
précises pour l'aéronautique ou encore
le spatial
seulement avec la crise la pme de 20
personnes qui se portait bien a vu son
chiffre d'affaires baisser d'environ 30
pour
il fallait donc trouver une solution
pour préserver les emplois et continuer
l'activité
d'où cette idée géniale d'utiliser le
savoir faire de la pme pour inventer un
petit crochet qui se vissent à la main
dans votre mur
pas besoin d'outils donc pour accrocher
un tableau ou un autre objet de
décoration au mur ce système de fixation
s'appelle l'attachante il suffit de la
vie c'est à la main on est loin du coeur
de métier de précise dec mais
l'entreprise a su rebondir de manière
spectaculaire
récemment dans ouest-france fils bansard
le dirigeant précisé l'objectif est que
dans les six mois cette pièce représente
10% de notre volume de ventes
nous sommes en phase de développement
dit il mais on va très vite ça va plus
vite que ce que l'on imaginait elle peut
tenir jusqu'à 8 kg de charge et son prix
varie de 4 à 7 euros pièce elle arrive
sur le marché
est ce que l'on peut retenir de cette
histoire c'est la formidable capacité de
nos pme à se réinventer
alors oui nous avons des talents dans
nos territoires ce sont ces entreprises
qui dans les prochains mois sans nul
doute devrait être le moteur principal
de la relance économique
merci michel picaud on se retrouve dans
une prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires on pensait son temps révolu
mais elle revient en force
la consigne en bretagne à rennes
précisément une entreprise s'est lancé
sur le marché et propose notamment des
plats en verre pour les restaurateurs et
la vente à emporter
rennes en boîte pas selon l'entreprise
répond ainsi à une demande galopante
c'est un reportage de philippe bertout
pour la chaîne locale tvr par heinze
à rennes ce matin rue nantaise tristan
vient livrer de nouvelles boîtes le show
chapka fait est l'un des premiers
restaurants avoir répondu à l'appel de
rennes en boîte le plat en octobre 2020
on a à disposition des commerçants des
boîtes en verre que peuvent proposer à
leurs clients contre une consigne de 3
euros pour leurs commandes remportées et
ensuite cette boîte les clients peuvent
leur apporter dans n'importe quel
commerce qui fait partie du réseau soit
pour se faire rosser rieur ce soit pour
récupérer leurs consignes et pour ce
restaurant le service correspond à une
demande du client
les clients adorent l'initiative ils
sont vraiment intéressés par le projet
pour eux ça va vraiment dans le cadre de
tout ce que les utilisations
d'être un peu plus écolo même démarche
pour la clara établissements du haut de
la place de la mairie
là aussi c'est le client qui pousse au
changement enfin c'est vrai qu'on a eu
une demande des clients qui connaissait
aussi en boîte le plat et c'est vrai
qu'on les avait sollicités et on a
relancé la machine en fait en disant que
nous nos clients avec cette demande est
depuis hier d'ailleurs on a deux deux
sociétés qui viennent régulièrement
manger chez nous qui nous ont demandés
en fait de n'utiliser que ces boîtes là
pour eux et pour leurs salariés
ainsi les boîtes peuvent s'utiliser et
s'échanger dans les 25 restaurants de
rennes et six sont sévigné qui ont dit
oui au concept
il leur en coûte 20 groupes un mois
d'abonnement un coup de projecteur à
présent dans ce grand jt des territoires
sur des actions solidaires d'un chef son
nom bruno cerrato exilé aux états unis
ce français lutte contre la pauvreté et
la faim grâce à la distribution de repas
en plus de 15 ans d'action avec son
association il a déjà servi des millions
de repas notamment aux plus jeunes vous
allez le voir en déplacement à monaco où
il a pu s'entretenir avec l'archevêque
de la principauté
bruno cerrato s'est aussi confié à la
rédaction de monaco info sur son action
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
écoutez les beaucoup de gens qu'ils
aiment bien faire du bien mais ils ne
sachent pas comment le faire mais avec
moi à transférer des vidéos des photos
je fais voir où j'en ce qu'on fait je
parle avec les discours que ceux dans le
monde et explique exactement comment ça
commence et où on est arrivé aujourd'hui
de devoir servir 6 millions de repas à
des enfants qu'ils ont besoin sans gros
numéros j'ai toujours urgent ne
commencez pas avec un million j'ai
commencé avec un enfant une passe dans
un pays dans un club
maintenant on est dans 30 villes et 90
location
c'est une maladie rare et méconnu ni al
21 ans et surnommé l'enfant lé une
atteinte d'une maladie génétique qui
l'empêchent de s'exposer aux uv elle est
obligée de se protéger du soleil avec un
casque et des vêtements spéciaux tout
son quotidien est évidemment impacté par
cette maladie qui ne concerne que
quelques dizaines d'enfants en france ni
à l'est la seule enfant lune du
département de la loire adrien bletterie
de la chaîne tl7 a passé l'après midi
avec elle regardait ça y est ni à les
équiper pour sortir dehors des gants
anti-uv un aux manches longues
imperméable aux rayons et un casque
dernière génération avant j'avais un mal
classé qui recouvrait vraiment tout mon
visage là au moins on peut voir ma
petite heure et du coup il est équipé
d'un ventilateur parce que sinon j'avais
pas à respirer intérieur j'étouffe et il
est je le branche à une batterie externe
du coup voilà jeu
la lune comme ça direction les courses
pour nihal à chaque fois elles se
rendent dans le même centre commercial
toujours muni de son appareil
aujourd'hui ni elle s'est habituée au
regard des gens et aux remarques natif
d'algérie sa vie aurait pu basculer très
tôt c'est assez on va dire atypiques
comme comme équipement et tout ça et du
coup ça peut impressionner
certaines personnes et c'est pour ça que
je comprends et que des fois même j'en
joue mes parents et mon ils ont ils ont
tous quitté ils ont pu lâcher ils ont
ils ont refait leur vie a ici pour moi
et j'ai eu l'occasion de voilà deux
d'avoir on va dire les soins nécessaires
et tout ça il n'y a pas de traitement
encore pour cette maladie en france il y
à une centaine d'enfants lune qui chaque
jour affronte le soleil pour vivre
pleinement leur vie sans transition en
martinique
à l'occasion du 60e anniversaire du
régiment du service militaire adapté les
recrues se sont lancés dans la
rénovation du refuge dit du chinois sur
la montagne pelée
tous les mardis et les jeudis ces jeunes
font l'ascension du volcan avec
plusieurs dizaines de kilos de matériel
sur le dos un défi à relever en équipe
et en se montrant solidaire
reportage de tom ganio pour la chaîne
via atv sur place martinique
5h30 au pied de la montagne pelée
dernières consignes pour les jeunes
stagiaires du rsm avant l'ascension
il faut récupérer les sacs et les
préparer à l'intérieur une charge de 15
kilos de pierres près d'une heure de
marche à flanc de falaise a dansé
volontaire c'est quand même assez
difficile sur le début après on reprend
une guérite mais ça va un peu mieux
et puis moi comme ça la première fois
l'avantagé c'est que je ne sais pas
trouvé l'arrivée donc voilà je n'arrive
pas trop à me situer donc j'avance pour
l'instant ça va c'est la partie qu'on
vient de franchir la qui est un peu
réd sinon les restes savoir et après
plusieurs minutes de marche les
premières douleurs apparaissent ça va
mais les jeunes qui prennent dans cette
opération l'entr'aide entre les recrues
est primordiale car c'est aussi
l'objectif de la matinée mettre l'accent
sur les valeurs collectives
il n'y a pas de notion de vitesse sur
cette montée l'important c'est que
l'ensemble arriveront donc l'entr'aide
donc apprendre d'eux de soi même et à
prendre de la force du groupe
ils sont près de 150 membres du rsm à a
participé à cette opération
en tout dix tonnes de pierres vont être
amenées au sommet une étape essentielle
pour la réhabilitation du refuge de
phases vont être nécessaires
la première celle de l'assainissement et
donc c'est ce qui nous amène aujourd'hui
les cadres et volontaires du régiment
150 par jour monte à environ 15 kilos
alors sac à dos 2-2 pierre pour
permettre le justement le drainage
autour du site
le groupe arrive au refuge les corps
peuvent enfin se reposer
la satisfaction est sur tous les visages
oui là si contente c'est mon chef de
section m'a beaucoup aidé mon chef de
file est aussi quelque chose à faire là
franchement c'est quelque chose qu'on
finit seule fois dans sa vie donc autant
profiter de l'affrontement
pas de temps à perdre tous les sacs de
pierres sont vides et les stagiaires
rentrer à la caserne la même journée les
attend jeudi prochain on referme ce
grand jt des territoires avec du
football en pleine compétition de l'euro
à quelques jours du huitième de finale
de l'équipe de france contre la suisse
les plus petits jouent aussi au ballon
rond en corse se tenir il ya quelques
jours l'étape locale de la champion's
cup
cette compétition qui a pour objectif de
mettre en avant le football amateur
rassemble des futurs champions âgés de
10 à 12 ans sébastien piocelle et le
coordinateur de la champion's cup
écoutez le au micro dans ce genre signé
de kara serrano devient telle est pas
aisé sur place la six étapes donc on a
commencé à lyon mercredi dernier on est
en corse aujourd'hui
ce sera mercredi prochain à mérignac
pour les vies sont de bordeaux ensuite
on ira aux sables d'olonne pour le grand
os paris et marseille pour finir ensuite
la grande finale 7 juillet au stade
vélodrome il ya un vainqueur par étapes
sachant que les quatre grosses étapes
bordeaux paris lyon marseille il ya 48
clubs donc c-232 24 y en a deux ce qui
fait qu il y aura dix finalistes garçons
en le 7 juillet le rendez vous est donc
pris à marseille le 7 juillet pour la
finale de la challenge cup soit quatre
jours avant la finale de l'euro où nous
espérons bien sûr retrouver équipe de
france voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt
des territoires merci de l'avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales et
sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition attrait victoire
[Musique]